de plus en plus diversifié,
les Forces armées ststent encore
une affaire d'hommes blancs.
Ils représentent 71 % des
selon un nouveau rapport.
Et les as s s se sentent
parfois exclus ou discriminés.
- Oui, j'ai vu le racisme...
un Cri du Manitoba, a goûté
aux insultes dès le début
de sa carrière militaire.
sur la base de Valcartier.
ROBERT FALCON-OUELLETTE,
réserviste, Forces armées can.
le Royal 22e Régiment, mon
commandant, il a dit : "Il y a
trois choses qu'on n'aime pas
on n'aime pas les anglophones,
on n'aime pas les femmes
et on n'aime pas
- Et surtout, il ne savait
pas où se plaindre.
- Les personnes qui m'ont
pour prévenir le harcèlement.- ,
le problème est loin d'être
réglé, constate la ministre
ANITA ANAND, ministre
de la Défense nationale
- Nous devons reconnaître que
la discrimination exisd d d d dr
rapidement pour mettre fin
au harcèlement et pour rendre
le processus de recrutement
et de promotiorcrcrcrcrcrcrcrcr.
Car, depuis 20 ans,
plus de 40 rapports ont été
présentés au ministère, et les
recommmises de côté ou abandonn.
CHARLOTTE DUVAL-LANTInInInInst.
canadien affaires mondialeslllle
il n'y a pas entntntntnt
de progrès, c'est parce quennnns
l'emphase cococococomportements
individuels au lieu de prendreos
struct c c c c culturels.
- Reste qu'il y a quand mêmendnr
de c c c c comme ces militaires
qui croient au suprémacisme
des Forces armées soupçonnéoioie
droite a foncé avec
la résidence officielledededede.
Selon le rapport, l'adhésion
en croissance et elle devient
de plus en plus clandestine.
SANDRA PERRON, majore à la
retraite, Forces aisisisisisisis
identifier. Ils se réinventent
à tout bout de champ.
C'est une grande préoccupation.
- Ultimemeisisisisisisisisisisit
néfastes pour les militaires
qui subissent les insultes
ou la discrimination.
Elleààààààààààààààààààààààààààà,
qui peine à attirer de nouvelles
recrues depuis plusieurs années.
Ici Laurence Martin,